al menos en cuatro oportunidades el
gobierno intentó abrir las escuelas pero
fue finalmente hasta este lunes que se
concretó el regreso a las aulas luego de
año y ocho meses paradas por la pandemia
del cohete 19 abre las escuelas al mismo
tiempo que inicia en algunos de estos
centros educativos la vacunación de
niños mayores de 12 años antes de volver
a la presencialidad los educadores si
habían pedido mejoras en las condiciones
de bioseguridad
infraestructura y salario en muchos
casos no fueron atendidos a estos
requerimientos
dos ejemplos puntuales una de las
escuelas que visitamos hace unos días no
tenía por ejemplo agua en los baños ni
electricidad en los salones y dos
hablamos con un profesor que nos contaba
que no gana ni siquiera cinco dólares al
mes por eso muchos de estos se oponían
al regreso a la presencialidad el gran
reto ahora es para los profesores que
tendrán que nivelar a los estudiantes
que pasaron de grado sin tener
competencias necesarias atrás una
educación a distancia que alega no
funcionó sin embargo la vuelta a clase
se desarrolló este lunes con total
normalidad y aunque el llamado sí a
clases presenciales es parte de una
orden ejecutiva para los más de 29.000
100 planteles del país algunos no
pudieron sumarse debido a estas mismas
condiciones de infraestructura u
organización para recibir a los alumnos